here's the uh here's the story yeah big
mouth on chris gosh guys guys
earlier today
i'm reading this alex berenson thing
about how the white house uh basically
instructed or demanded his suspension
and i'm like wow that's a huge story and
then all of a sudden i see people
talking about like hey you see the
former head of the cia calling for
trump's execution and i was like what
and so i looked i was like okay he's not
really calling for it he's just saying
that should happen basically
and so here's so
i'm just kind of out of it like um last
night someone mentioned that joe rogan
said on the show
he thought i was crazy when i said civil
war was coming and now he thinks i'm
right
and so uh they sent the clip to me and i
played it earlier on my morning show and
it's just kind of like nam what jack
called it like tim pool is right night
or whatever i don't know what you were
saying simple is right weak right weak
uh yeah but you know it's it's just like
it's easy to call it things that you get
right i got a lot of things wrong i you
know made that clear but here's the
story trump is under investigation for
violating the espionage act after fbi
recovered 11 sets of classified
documents from mar-a-lago full warrant
is unsealed but ex-president insists he
declassified everything which he can and
so uh
i thought they said he was uh got the
nuclear documents what happened to that
story washington post what are they
saying now it's a broad search warrant
it's not it's not the search warrant
says all
all documents for the entirety of his
presidency so
the the piece that we have here and
human events.com actually dropped this
an hour before anybody else today we
when we got our copy of it remember
the story has changed every single day
of the week because at one point where
it was the newsweek piece the newsweek
piece says
two
high-level justice officials tell us
they're authorized authorized to tell
newsweek that the department of justice
had absolutely nothing to do with this
raid that it was all the fbi it was
completely driven by them it was rey
these guys out of dc these numb skulls
they were the ones behind it and even
though by the and they just grudgingly
admit way down at the bottom of the
newsweek article that and by the way of
course there is a grand jury in dc
that's you know looking up to indict the
former president for crimes but don't
worry about that and then garland comes
out the next day and says it actually
was him who authorized the raid then the
night before we're told but he oh but
what does garland say to us garland says
to us it was narrow in scope okay narrow
in scope immediately he walks off stage
he's this this deranged you know he's
like five six i called him a um i called
him a deranged eunuch and
we get the leak to the washington post
the washington post has nuclear codes
right nuclear documents nuclear
basically
we don't know if it's pretty pertaining
to weapons in the united states or
elsewhere right so it's like they didn't
know actually right well and here here's
the thing right you know um
kind of the no cap response to that is
that
obviously the nuclear codes get changed
on a very regular it's very frequent
basis could you imagine if it's like i'm
no longer the president for over a year
now
but we're not going to change the launch
codes change the locks he's he's in the
well this is you know this is the big
meme on on sort of like mega twitter
right now is that it's now we've gone
from nuclear or so ultra mega it's a
nuclear mega so that that's right that's
right trump never never gave up the
nuclear codes he's got him down there at
mar-a-lago baron trump is gathering the
fizzle material he's got four he's got
four nuclear turbines already he's
working towards 10. um you know they're
they're targeting rehobeth beach you
know all the rest of it so the memes
have just been flying absolutely flying
and uh unlike the missiles which are not
flying hopefully though we'll keep an
eye we'll keep an eye on all that but no
they they said that it was narrow in
scope but then we get so when i posted
the documents this afternoon i said wait
a minute it says right here all
documents
from the president's archives from
january 20th 2017 all the way to january
20th 2021. well that's the entire scope
of his presidency so that's why you're
seeing things in this inventory sheet
which we also posted that say things
like the roger stone pardon is in there
or like letters between himself and
emmanuel macron
that's that's every single document it's
a fishing expedition
but that's okay because because the
judge that signed off on this is one of
the best judges in the country just
definitely not connected to any scandals
or he did a really good job helping
epstein's lieutenants he did a wonderful
job it was interesting because
here's what happened okay he on he
started as a epstein prosecutor
and then in the course of prosecuting
epstein he realized that it was a
wrongful prosecution and that he had to
help out and do the right thing not for
himself tim but for the good of the
country and the good of abstinence so
he resigns from the u.s this is dead
serious resigns from the u.s attorney's
office
and then goes to work for epstein's you
know organization represents
not not jack that represents the pilot
represents the lieutenant those in order
to help save them freedom those actions
represent america basically john he's
basically the new john adams what is
this so they they they raided trump and
now he's oh wait wait and and just and
now he's a judge
what was the justification for this
search warrant though then we still
don't have it we actually
actually still don't have it the war was
like give us everything so here okay
okay okay so here's you know joking
aside here's here's the serious part of
it
there is another missing piece to this
and that's the answer to your question
because you're reading this thing and
we're looking at the seven pages of the
warrant and the property inventory and
you're saying wait where's the
where's the so what why can we just
authorize fbi agents to go do this right
and so they're supposed to be an
affidavit and the affidavit is what's
given to the judge to get him to
authorize the search warrant we don't
have that yet
they haven't released it
jack
civil war
i mean
and tim here's so here's like don't sell
yourself short right because
when you're when you're talking for as
many hours a week as we do right
we're bound to get a lot wrong we're
bound to make misstatements we're bound
to just have predictions that don't pan
out etc but your big prediction of the
where where all of this was going over
the last five six years you've always
said this is headed towards and maybe
you know maybe tomorrow
joe biden comes out crying and says
i am stopping this charade donald trump
is a good man
and we cannot allow the weaponization of
the doj i hereby resign and and then
everyone cheers and biden supporters
that's not what i'm hearing
pink hats are hugging maga hats in the
street people are they throw them in the
air together
what's that meme of like blm and mega
like you know fist bumping for the
better yeah no that's not what i'm
hearing at all in fact what i'm hearing
out of dc is that you're hearing a lot
of democrats are going to the white
house saying okay the way to fix this is
to lean into it because because what
they're what they're from this line of
thinking which might sound completely
crazy and by the way joe biden's down
there in south carolina he's definitely
not going to jekyll island by the way
that's no no nothing which word you know
nothing ever happened there and um
and
they're saying that you have to lean in
because since you raided him right
now it looks political but if you indict
him
then it looks like you're just following
the facts
right as if they had a plan all along
because it was an actual crime and
it so they're actually people advising
president biden right now to indict
donald j trump so and
just if you look at as caustic of a
situation
that this country's been in for the last
six years even for the last six months
right i think we all
could just pull back and you know
take off the red hat take off the pit
whatever hat you know and just say
that's probably not a good place we want
to take people into so this episode from
of the rogan podcast comes out last
night someone super chatted us saying
joe said he thought he was crazy now he
thinks he's right and uh what i didn't
realize until
this morning i was like wait a minute
they pre-record those shows right joe
didn't even know at the time of
recording that that some dude went to an
fbi building and tried to bust through
the bulletproof glass shooting at fbi
agents before fleeing and being killed
when he recorded that segment that had
not happened it hadn't even happened yet
and so um
it's kind of crazy because i'm wondering
what's going through joe's mind now with
that news hitting after he said this a
few days ago he's probably thinking like
well i was right about thinking tim was
right now right because that's that's a
whole whole new level of crazy of course
people
people on the right think this was a
false flag
i i look i understand exactly where
people believe it and i'll put it this
way
the fact that people believe this guy
in cincinnati was a false flag shows and
and it's widespread too like hardcore
trump supporters across the border like
no way that's real just goes to show the
disdain and distrust for the federal
government especially with you know what
we saw with ray epps so people are just
not ready to believe well and you you're
following the whitmer case because
that's coming out right now the next
iteration of it and julie kelly has been
doing such great work on this and
they're having to admit in court that
fbi agents or fbi assets were planting
explosives in the trunk of cars you had
another fbi informant and i'm just
following julie's reporting they said
the fbi informant was not only staying
in the same hotel as the target not only
staying in the same hotel room but yes
as you can imagine she was sleeping in
the same bed as the target so just full
on not just honey pot operations like
the eric swalwell style with fang fang
no no no this is honey pot operations to
treat you into trick you into actually
committing domestic terrorism acts and
then prosecuting you thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there